je vais vous parler aujourd'hui des
nouveaux buzz de google les pixels bugs
pro qui sont là juste là alors pour
tester les picks and rolls pro on prend
quoi eh bien on prend un smartphone de
google et si j'ai appris le pixel six
pros on prend bien évidemment la boîte à
sorties l'étui est là c'est vachement
intéressant parce qu'en fait c'est la
première fois que google arrive avec des
bugs avec une réduction brute l'actif
d'une montée en gamme honda veut dire il
arrive que les pixels bugs à jeter pas
de bêtises qui est pas mal à moins de
100 euros la remontant les à 219 euros
on arrive donc en frontal avec plein
d'autres marques qui ont déjà fait
plusieurs versions de bugs comme ça avec
une réduction de bruit active on va donc
regarder merlus que ça raconte est ce
que google a réussi son pari est ce
qu'il est au niveau est-ce qu'il a
encore du chemin à faire bref est ce que
ces pixels buzz pro sont intéressants ou
alors pas du tout ouais bah oury bah non
[Musique]
la première chose à voir c'est ce qui se
passe dans la boîte alors regardez on
écarte ça vous allez voir il ya un truc
assez intéressant il mais quand je dis
ça intéressant c'est que en fait vous
avez bien votre étui qui est situé juste
là alors on enlève l'étui on enlève ça
on a ici et bien différentes tailles
d'embouts pour pouvoir l'adapter à
l'oreille de chaque col donc ça c'est
plutôt pas mal et c'est assez logique
vous avez ensuite un petit guide de
démarrage carte de garantie et compagnie
tout se situe la baie le truc que je
trouve qu'il manque réellement déjà il
manque un câble usb c'est pour venir
recharger alors me direz-vous toujours
d'un câble usb c'est mais la plupart du
temps ce que vous allez venir acheter
des buzz je tairai même quasiment tout
le temps j'ai jamais vu de bugs comme ça
où vous n'aviez pas de câble eh bien
vous avez un petit câble pour venir le
brancher en plus parce que si vous avez
déjà un câble probablement est il déjà
utilisés donc là on n'a pas de câble usb
c'est vers usb c'est ou usb c'est vers
usb à pour venir le charger et ça a ses
trucs que je trouve un peu dommage bon
une fois qu'on a passé ce truc là on
retrouve un étui qui est assez cool
format un peu galets grand galet un peu
dont ça ça me convient aussi c'est
vraiment fort voire trouver chez google
vous les ouvrez alors le premier truc
qui est vachement cool lorsque vous
l'ouvrez comme ça vous avez dû face perd
donc vous venez le connecter très
rapidement et notamment à votre
smartphone android alors moi il est déjà
père est donc bon fatalement à l'avenir
se connecter facilement donc ça c'est
très bien pour un premier repérage donc
vous l'ouvrez taxe sap est regardé par
exemple là ils veulent recoller
directement je vois mon niveau de
batterie c'est l'expérience google 100%
google 100% optimisé pour google et palm
eagle donc fatalement les planètes
s'alignent donc ça c'est plutôt bien
premiers points 2e point lorsque je les
ai vu que les ouvert et bien je prends
mais un petit buzz dans la main alors là
c'est pareil on est surtout qu'un petit
peu pas standard mais c'est des buzz on
connaît déjà un peu l'histoire avec tous
les capteurs vous allez pouvoir avoir
bon ok ça fonctionne c'est plutôt cool
en terme de tenue et de confort alors on
vient les prendre regardez on va venir
sera prochain peut vous le prenez vous
le mettez et vous le tournez un peu
comme ça comme des bugs un peu standard
donc on voulait aller prendre on vient
les tournées convient les mettre
directement au plat dans l'or est comme
ça alors la tenue je la trouve pas
mauvaise mais c'est pas là où je vais
trouver la meilleure tenue par rapport à
pas mal de bugs que j'ai je suis venu
écouter alors on pourrait se dire ok est
ce que c'est la taille de mes en bout
qui n'est pas la bonne auquel cas je
vais venir changer j'essaie je vois le
confort qui me convient de facto comme
ça c'est pas là que j'ai trouvé le
meilleur confort après à vous de voir
alors il ça ce que vous pouvez faire
directement ici dans votre application
ou vous saurait si ça convient ici à
tailler bonheur moi j'ai fait le test la
taille est bonne c'est bon ça fonctionne
à vous de voir parce que ça va dépendre
des oreilles de chacun il ya d'autres
bugs que j'ai pu essayer je crois que
confort est un peu meilleure bon mais
c'est pas mal franchement c'est pas mal
sont un peu plus gros ils sortent un peu
plus que certain que j'ai pu également
testé bon c'est pas forcément un truc
qui va être rédhibitoire parce que une
fois de plus aux dépens de l'oreille de
chacun ça dépend du conduit auditif de
chacun donc bon j'aime bien la copie
j'aime bien les bugs j'aime bien l'idée
ils sont très cool donc ça c'est un peu
pour le début pour la découverte
maintenant ce qui est vraiment
intéressant à ce qui est venu faire
google ici c'est qu'en fait ils sont
venus mettre un processeur adapté
spécialement pour google la même manière
ce qu'ils ont fait à partir des pixels 6
puis celle ci ce problème chronique
celle ci ça aujourd'hui avec laure plus
google tensor abeilles font des puces
maison on les a on veut vivre un plan
d'autonomie avec notre design personnel
au niveau notre puce pour adapter
complètement à nos usagers un besoin de
nos consommateurs donc là c'est pareil
nous ont fait un processeur maison pour
avoir une vraie expérience google parce
qu en fait l'idée de ce buzz argument
c'est d'écouter de la musique c'est de
profiter d'une expérience google à fond
notamment vous allez le prendre et vous
allez dire ok google et de moi à parler
espagnol et deux mois par les onglets
deux mois par les finlandais j'en sais
rien filmé les deux mois par les chinois
et l'ufr la traduction en temps réel
donc ça c'est vachement cool ça permet
effectivement d'échanger directement
avec quelqu'un ou si vous êtes sur une
vidéo youtube qui pas dans la dans une
langue que vous parlez nous avoir une
traduction alors c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose que si vous compreniez
l'histoire mais malgré tout ça va venir
vous aider et pour ça et bien ils
passent par des processeurs par des
puces maison de la même manière on a un
algorithme maison c'est google google
fait du google donc une fois de plus
expérience vraiment optimisé pour les
services google tout en sachant qu'après
ils ont fait le choix de nous mettre un
haut parleur ici un petit driver de 11
mm jusque là ça me va bien maintenant le
truc un peu moins bon c'est toute
l'expérience en écoutant musique s'est
trouvé que il manque un petit quelque
chose dans les hauts médiums et dans les
aigus il manque une précision il manque
une clarté il manque des cymbales que
j'ai pas venir retrouver dans la tous
des morceaux qu'on connaît qu'on connaît
parfaitement bien et qu'on maîtrise et
lorsque je vais écouter quelques
morceaux de référence comme ça et bien
voyez jamais qu'ils entendent par
exemple une petite cymbales qui ne l'est
pas la gelée pas il manque complètement
alors pour autant ça va rouler un peu on
sent qu'il ya du grave derrière et c'est
flatteur mais toute la précision euros
il me manque un peu donc j'ai vraiment
ce médium qui est pas mal fichu médium
médium grave pas trouvé que les bases
sont les plus précises mais ce qui va me
gêner surtout c'est vraiment tout ces
fréquences plus aiguë aux médiums aigus
ou là je lui ai manqué de précision et
pour toutes les personnes qui vont
vouloir écouter du jazz même même
n'importe quelle musique un dès lors que
vous avez des fréquences un peu plus
aiguë que fatalement évidemment mais on
veut venir les chercher les entendre et
bien c'est s'est perdu et vous les avez
pas il se trouve ça dommage alors j'ai
fait le test avec la réduction
collective activé avec les réductions
doivent couper parce que des fois vous
avez un peu d'électronique et ça vous
mangez un peu le son ça c'est un peu le
point faible je trouve qu à 219 euros il
nous manque quelque chose par rapport à
d'autres concurrents si vous regardez
par exemple les galaxies buzz de procès
on va le retrouver on a toutes ces
fréquences aiguës qui sont précises et
là on les a pas et vous arrêtez
d'écouter de chez sony aussi vous
trouverez des choses avec beaucoup plus
de précision alors pour autant je jette
pas du tout la pierre à google n'est
vraiment pas c'est une première version
qui vont venir faire ici sur les pixels
bugs pro donc fatalement ils essayent
ils avancent et on n'avance pas par
passe des choses qui sont corrigés sur
les générations suivantes peut-être même
d'ailleurs que ce sera corrigé d'ici peu
de temps d'un point de vue purement
logicielle parce que vous avez des
drivers qui feront le taf qu'un qui
peuvent délivrer ces fréquences aiguës
mais bon voilà il manque encore des
choses il ya d'autres points qu'il faut
venir voir ici c'est la réduction de
bruit actif parce que c'est quand même
le truc qu'on nous promet ici on a eu la
réaction hâtive avec le silent hill en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que vous avez
deux choses première chose vaut bugs
comme iran quand même bien dans vos
oreilles et vous bougez bien les
oreilles vous avez une réduction de
bruit passif c'est à dire qu'on va venir
couper le son qui rentrent sont partis
mais évidemment c'est pas magique non
plus mais ça veut quand même pas trop
mal à lui sombré face ils fonctionnent
bien dès lors que vous avez trouvé les
embouts qui vont bien vos oreilles
voulait positionner voulait tourner on
est bon en plus de sa glace rajouter
quoi une réduction de bruit active là
vous avez des micros qui vont venir
capter le son extérieur qui vont le
comparer au micro à l'intérieur pour
convertir un différentiel entre
l'extérieur et le sont à l'intérieur de
vos oreilles et allégorique qui va dire
travailler et qui va faire ce qu'on
appellera un système de hors phase qui
va venir annulé en fait le son le son ce
sont des ondes et donc lui ce qui va
venir faire c'est créer la même monde
mais en négative ce qui fait qu'on va
venir annuel son éclosion n'existe plus
c'est le principe du hors phase en fait
tu trouves que franchement ça fonctionne
pas trop mal pour une première version
mais également à 219 euros jusque sur le
marché on trouve des écouteurs avec une
meilleure réduction de bruit active pour
autant et une fois de plus je le pense
je le dis je le redis c'est la première
version du groupe l'itie avec cette
réduction de bruit active donc ils ont
des choses à venir amélioré d'un point
de vue logiciel mais quand on connaît la
force de frappe de google je pense que
des choses qui vont venir soit corrigée
par une mise à jour soit par une version
au numéro deux d'un produit si ces
petits ajustements d'impôt de vue
matériel autre truc qu'on vient voir ici
dans ces bugs il ya c'est que vous avez
une application alors une application je
vous montre je me mets un buzz je vais
dans il advient dans mes paramètres
alors dans les paramètres je viens où je
viens juste là et pour me retrouver en
fait c'est pas une application native on
vient la télécharger comme de
l'application c'est dire que quand vous
allez dans le play store vous venez là
et vous venez chercher xl bugs hop là et
ça vous proposeriez l'application ici là
google pixels bugs sauf qu'en fait c'est
pas une vraie application vous cliquez
dessus et ça vous emmène dans vos
paramètres bluetooth c'est à dire que
vous venez ici vous allez dans les
paramètres de votre smartphone vous
allez sur bluetooth et votre appareil à
côté vous avez la petite roue dentée et
c'est là vous allez voir vous paramètres
donc a pas une vraie application à côté
de ça vous a gardé pas mal de choses ici
donc ça c'est plutôt bien c'est à dire
que vous venez retrouver effectivement
ben le niveau de batterie vous venez
retrouver la mise à jour logicielle
votre assistant google avec les
différentes préférences ok pour venir
chercher si vous perdez vos pixels bbl
dre pour venir les retrouver ici le
choix de venir mettre la réduction de
bruit de la désactiver ou de mettre le
mot de transparence au caire géométrie
deux comme ça qui me paraît que le mode
transparence vous allez voir que le mot
transparence fonctionne très bien donc
là j'ai mon mode transparence ok donc
j'ai switché bonne transparence
activer/désactiver suppression de bruit
bon ok ça fonctionne je vais avoir
ensuite à toutes mes commandes tactiles
ça c'est pareil elle marche très très
bien allan poe et françois de désactiver
si vous le souhaitez pour venir les
personnaliser sur un appui prolongé
notamment appui prolongé écouteurs droit
blanc moi j'ai mis activer désactiver la
réduction de bruit donc ça c'est ici je
peux mettre la scission roumain si je le
souhaite et la même chose de l'autre
côté et puis ensuite je peux venir
chang'e 2 3 modes lorsque je veux dire
par exemple activer désactiver mal
adduction bruit et bien je peux mettre
la suppression de bruit ou le mode
transparence et si je veux je peux
mettre aussi le mode désactiver ça
dépendra de vous ça dépendra de ce que
vous voulez en faire essayer ça et
ensuite on vous explique comment ça
marche vous faites glisser vers l'avant
où montent elles sont faites glisser
dans la r vous baissez le son vous
appuyer une fois lecture pause vous
appuyé deux fois à morceau suivant trois
fois morceau précédent et lorsqu'on vous
appelle vous appuyer une fois vous
répondez vous appuyé deux fois vous
refuser l'appel et je trouve ça vraiment
pas mal et ça fonctionne bien ça se
personnalise bon ok l'âge et tous les
paramètres ça marche très bien ou pas de
soucis venir tester l'ajustement ici
savoir le basculement audio activé vous
voyez ici hop là votre casque changer de
source audio directement en fonction de
ce que vous faites donc ça ça marche ok
je vais avoir le multipoint si je veux
me connecter appareil à différents
appareils très facilement et après je
vois d'autres paramètres ici mise en
pause automatique mise à jour du
micrologiciel à propos notification par
e-mail bon je passe le truc et ensuite
je peux venir coacher décocher les
appels téléphoniques c'était autorise
directement par des bugs ou pas l'audio
hd a assez alors ça c'est pareil c'est
un truc voyez je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage parce qu'en fait ici au niveau
collègues j'ai juste de la ces et du sbc
c'est tout travail minimum et il va
venir manqué certains codecs qui vont
être plutôt intéressant et qui me
permettront de venir maximiser
l'expérience et la qualité audio donc ça
c'est pareil c'est pas ça c'est un tout
qui sera corrigé peut-être un
partenariat avec qualcomm pourrait-il
être envisagé à l'avenir j'en sais rien
un multimédia bein je veux dire cochet
décocher des choses si je souhaite bon
pourquoi pas donc ça c'est quand même
bien l'application allait pas mal elle
est assez complète pour pourrait vouloir
encore en devenir apparaître d'autres
options il ya deux trucs que je vais
venir reproché le premier truc c'est que
l'application elle se situe uniquement
dans vos paramètres vous n'avez pas de
vraie de vraie application pour venir
installer à trifouiller bon elle est
quand même là l existant dans vos
paramètres donc on la trouve assez
facilement il faut venir cliqué dont les
paramètres dans le bluetooth et là vous
la retrouverez donc il faut quand même
venir un peu en profondeur pour y avoir
accès premier point et puis le deuxième
point c'est que c'est une application
qui est android uniquement droid et que
pour android donc si vous avez un iphone
évidemment et sont compatibles ios un
nom de poésie utilise avec un iphone
mais pour autant l'application tech vous
l'avez là et bien vous n'aurez pas sur
un os et ça c'est quand même un peu
dommage et après google nous annonce un
autre truc alors qu'ils aient pas
présent tout de suite mais qui va
arriver à l'avenir c'est le spacieux
l'audio l'audio spatialisé ça je vous en
ai parlé notamment au niveau des
galaxies botte de pros bien c'est fait
d'avoir un audio de 12 passagers qui
veut dire ouvrir un peu le spectre et ça
ça arrivera à l'automne c'est une mise à
jour qui arrivera n'en voyais ça
intéresse on anticipe le quai d'autres
mises à jour qui se déploient pour venir
améliorer la qualité améliorer la
réduction bout et petit à petit que les
jets les choses deviennent être un peu
plus sexy je précise que mon nom dans
cette vidéo on est en août 2022 parlons
l'autonomie ça c'est un truc qui est
intéressant parce que l'autonomie si
elle est quand même plutôt bonne on nous
annonce jusqu'à 7 heures d'écouté avec
la réduction de bruit active et et
jusqu'à 11 heures des coûts' ans la
réduction de bruit active et autant vous
diapos qu à l aller un petit peu loin et
là je parle qu'au niveau des bugs parce
que si vous rajoutez votre rechargement
ici vous allez dire pousser jusqu'à 20h
avec la réduction de bruit active et et
jusqu'à trente et une heures avec la
réduction de bruit couper tout en
sachant que pour venir recharger
évidemment ici en usb c'est bon vous
avez pas de câble soit vous allez en
acheter un soin vous en avait déjà soit
vous pouvez venir utiliser un chargeur
compatible cuit pour bien le recharger
sans fil très facilement tout en sachant
que le pixel stand de deuxième
génération lui est compatible donc si
vous avez déjà un pixel stand 2 bien
pouvait venir le prend pour venir
charger ici qu'aux petits bugs mais là
où c'est vraiment intéressant et comme
c'est l'expérience google optimisée pour
google c'est le fameux donc et google
vous pouvez venir lui demander tout ce
que vous voulez tout ce que google sait
faire il saura le faire et il va venir
vous lire vos notifications c'est à dire
vous allez avoir votre agenda vous allez
voir vos sms de l'avoir à vos emails
vous allez avoir des informations trafic
d'art informations sur le vol dans
l'avion enfin pas mal d'informations
intéressantes ici mounir vous faciliter
un petit peu la vie ici bien évidemment
vos bottes senti fier ipx4 donc le
résistant latium pour venir faire du
sport avec le boîtier lui ne l'est pas
c'est le leap x 2 go bon avenir éviter
le fait rencontrer de la flotte pour
éviter les soucis et on a ici du
bluetooth 5.0 alors globalement quel
retour vous donner que vous dire sur ces
pixels bugs pro pas mal mais à 219 euros
c'est pas là dessus que j'irai je vous
dis une fois de plus c'est à titre
d'exemple il y en a d'autres mais vous
avez les galaxies botte de projets ça
parce que j'ai fait le test et pas
longtemps 229 euros c'est 10 euros de
plus mais on a du spatial audio on a le
dolby head tracking
on a pas mal de choses et on a une
meilleure qualité audio de base qu'on
n'a pas tout de suite ici donc je trouve
que effectivement google pouvait pas une
lumière qui m'a lâché google pouvait pas
arriver en disant bon bah on va faire un
produit de la réduction de bruit active
avec du son pour eux de qualité même si
encore du taf et se mettre beaucoup
moins cher parce qu'il y aurait pas eu
de crédibilité donc il a fallu forcément
venir s'aligner mais il est évident que
même si ces pixels bugs profonde jolies
promesses même si sur le papier c'est
intéressant même si google va vraiment
propose des choses quand même faux
principes qui sont alléchants pour
l'instant c'est pas au niveau de la
concurrence à tarif égal donc si on
arrive à les trouver un peu moins cher
je vous dirais vers 160 euros pourquoi
pas mais à
219 euros pour moi il sait pas tout de
suite là dessus qu'il faut aller voir
les correctifs qu'on pourra voir dans
les semaines voire les mois à venir et
potentiellement voir ce qui arrivera
avec une version de pixels buzz deux
pros qui serait peut-être en tout cas je
l'espère plus aboutie et avec une
meilleure maîtrise de la part de google
bon à ce que j'avais à vous dire
aujourd'hui donc je les conseille pas
nécessairement mais c'est intéressant de
voir l'évolution de google dans l'audio
avec une gamme qui va être plus large au
niveau de ses pixels belge donc je sais
pas vous ce que vous en pensez ce que
vous avez déjà eu des pics elbeuf à
pourquoi pas qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ces pixels de ce point vous avez
acheté ce que vous avez envie de les
acheter ce qui vous tente dites moi ce
que vous en pensez juste en bas en
commentaire et puis bien évidemment on
continuera à parler de google parce que
les produits sont super intéressant font
super alléchant soit sur les smartphones
sur les écouteurs aussi messi encore un
peu tape là dessus sur plein d'autres
produits que l'écosystème temps c'est
très chouette on se retrouve vous très
bientôt pour continuer à parler de teck
et ça aussi c'est chouette nous embrasse
beaucoup d'amour ou 10 ou 15
[Musique]